the world is changing in some really
profound ways and I worry that investors
aren't paying enough attention to some
of the biggest drivers of change
especially when it comes to
sustainability and by sustainability I
mean the really juicy things like
environmental and social issues and
corporate governance
I think it's reckless to ignore these
things because doing so can jeopardize
future long-term returns and here's
something that may surprise you
the balance of power to really influence
sustainability rests with institutional
investors the large investors like
pension funds foundations and endowments
I believe that sustainable investing is
less complicated than you think
better performing than you believe and
more important than we can imagine let
me remind you what we already know we
have a population that's both growing
and aging
if 7 billion souls today headed to 10
billion at the end of the century we
consume natural resources faster than
they can be replenished in the emissions
that are mainly responsible for climate
change just keep increasing
now clearly these are environment on
social issues but that's not all their
economic issues and that makes some
relevant to risk in return and they are
really complex and they can seem really
far off that the temptation may be to do
this bury our heads in the sand and not
think about it resist this if you can
don't do this at home
but it makes me wonder if the investment
rules of today are fit for purpose
tomorrow
we know that investors when they look at
a company and decide whether to invest
they look at financial data metrics like
sales growth cash flow market share
valuation you know the really sexy stuff
and these things are fundamental of
course but they're not enough investors
should also look at performance metrics
and what we call ESG environment social
and governance environment includes
energy consumption water availability
waste and pollution just making
efficient uses of resources social
includes human capital things like
employee engagement in innovation
capacity as well as supply chain
management in labor rights and human
rights and governance relates to the
oversight of companies by their boards
and investors say I told you this is the
really juicy stuff
but if she is the measure of
sustainability and sustainable in that
senior corporates ESG factors with
financial factors into the investment
process it means limiting future risk by
minimizing harm to people and planet and
it means providing capital to users who
deploy it towards productive and
sustainable outcomes so sustainability
matters financially today and all signs
indicate more tomorrow is the private
sector paying attention well the really
cool thing is that most CEOs are they
started to see sustainability not just
as important but crucial to business
success about 80% of global CEOs he's
sustainability as the route to growth in
innovation and leading to competitive
advantage in their industries but 93%
see ESG as the future or as important to
the
sure of their business so the views of
CEOs are clear there's tremendous
opportunity in sustainability so how are
companies actually leveraging ESG to
drive hard business results
one example is near and dear to our
hearts in 2012 State Street migrated 54
applications to the cloud environment
and we retired another 85 we virtualized
our operating system environments and we
completed numerous automation projects
now these initiatives create a more
mobile workplace and they reduce our
real estate footprint and they yield
savings of 23 million dollars in
operating costs annually and avoid the
emissions of a hundred thousand metric
tons of carbon that's the equivalent of
taking 21,000 cars off the road it's
awesome right another example is Pentair
Pantera's a US industrial conglomerate
and about a decade ago they sold their
core power tools business and reinvested
those proceeds in a water business
that's a really big bet why do they do
that well with apologies to the home
improvement fans there's more growth in
water than in power tools and this
company has their sights set on what
they call the new new world that's four
billion middle-class people demanding
food energy and water now you may be
asking yourself are these just isolated
cases I mean come on really the
companies that take sustainability into
account really do well financially the
answer that may surprise you is yes the
data shows that stocks with better ESG
performance perform just as well as
others in blue we see the MSCI world
it's an index of large companies from
developed markets across the world and
in gold we see a subset of companies
rated as having the best DSU performance
over three plus years no performance
trade-off so that's ok right we want
more I want more in some cases there may
be out performance
from ESG and blue we see the performance
of the 500 largest global companies and
a goal we see a subset of companies with
best practice and climate change
strategy and risk management now over
almost eight years they've outperformed
by about two-thirds so yes this is
correlation is not causation but it does
illustrate that environmental leadership
is compatible with good returns so if
the returns are the same or better and
the planet benefits wouldn't this be the
norm our investors particularly
institutional investors engaged well
some are and a few are really at the
vanguard Hestia as does a retirement
fund for health and Community Services
employees in Australia with assets of 22
billion they believe that ESG is a
potential to impact risks and returns so
incorporating it into the investment
process is core to their duty to act in
the best interests of fund members
quarter their duty you gotta love the
Aussies right CalPERS is another example
CalPERS is the pension fund for public
employees in California and with assets
of 244 billion they are the second
largest in the US and the sixth largest
in the world now they're moving towards
a hundred percent sustainable investment
by systematically integrating ESG across
the entire fund why they believe it's
critical to superior long term returns
full-stop in their own words long term
value creation requires the effective
management of three forms of capital
financial human and physical this is why
we are concerned with the ESG now I do
speak to a lot of investors as part of
my job and not all of them see it this
way often I hear we are required to
maximize returns so we don't do that
here or we don't want to use the
portfolio to make policy statements
the one that just really gets under my
skin is if you want to do something
about that just make money give the
profits to charities eyes are rolling
eyes are rolling I mean let me clarify
something right here companies and
investors are not singularly responsible
for the fate of the planet they don't
have indefinite social obligations and
prudent investing and Finance Theory
aren't subordinate to sustainability
they're compatible so I'm not talking
about trade-offs here but institutional
investors are the x-factor in
sustainability
why do they hold the key the answer
quite simply is they have the money a
lot of it
I mean a really a lot of it the global
stock market is worth fifty five
trillion dollars the global bond market
seventy eight trillion that's one
hundred and thirty three trillion
trillion combined that's eight and a
half times the GDP of the US that's the
world's largest economy
that's some serious freaking firepower
so we can reconsider some of these
pressing challenges like fresh water
clean air feeding ten billion mouths if
institutional investors integrated ESG
into investment what if they use that
firepower to allocate more of their
capital to companies working the hardest
at solving these challenges or at least
not exacerbating them what if we work
and save and invest only and find that
the world we retire into is more
stressed and less secure than it is now
what if there isn't enough clean air
fresh water now a fair question might be
what if father sustainability risk stuff
is exaggerated overstated it's not
urgent something for virtuous consumers
a lifestyle choice well President John F
Kennedy said something about this that
is just spot-on there are risks and
costs to a program of action but they
are far less than the long-range risks
and costs of comfortable inaction
I can appreciate that there's estimation
risk in this but since this is based on
widespread scientific consensus the odds
that it's not completely wrong are
better than the odds that our house will
burn down or we're getting a car
accident
well maybe not if you live in Boston
but but my point is is that we buy
insurance to protect ourselves
financially in case those things happen
right so by investing sustainably we're
doing two things for creating insurance
reducing the risk to our planet into our
economy and at the same time in
short-term we're not sacrificing
performance
good you like it I like it too I like it
because it pokes funs at both sides of
the climate change issue I bet you can't
guess which side I'm on but what I
really like about it is that it reminds
me of something Mark Twain said which is
planned for the future because that's
where you're going to spend the rest of
your life
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]